- Oh, sorry sweetie, this chocolate bar
is actually really spicy.
You wouldn't like it.
("Gypsy Sailor")
- So big news, Santa called,
he wants you to take a nap.
- All right, you can stay
out here playing if you want,
just look out for that bear.
- I don't know what happened
to that very loud drum toy.
It must have gotten stolen.
- Sorry honey, the TV only
works when it's raining.
- Ah honey, Disneyland is closed today.
Mickey's sick.
- Actually, if the ice cream
truck is playing music,
that means they're out of ice cream.
- Sorry sweetheart, the soda
actually has coffee in it.
You wouldn't like it.
- No honey, that animal
at the side of the road
was just taking a nap.
- OK fine, I'm leaving without you.
- Oh, it's six o'clock,
internet lady is turning off
the world's internet for the night.
- I am serious mister, I am
starting the car right now.
- You know what happens
if you don't behave
in the drive-thru line?
They give you a sad meal.
- And we're gone, God
(bleep) Jackson, right now.
("Gypsy Sailor")